let's start with the doctor's early life
as he studied under a tutor named
Patrick blackett Oppenheimer at the time
was very unhappy in his life he
struggled with his lab work regularly
making mistakes and grappling with
depressive thoughts it was in this state
that Oppenheimer used a toxic chemical
to poison an apple on blackett's desk
the film showed us that he did this
because blacket made Oppenheimer relate
to a lecture by Niels Bohr but the real
reason and the real type of poison he
used is unknown to this day but he
really did try to poison his teacher
instead of hastily running to stop
Neil's board from accidentally eating it
the next day as shown in the film
however the university found out about
the attempted poisoning in Oppenheimer
was almost expelled the film also shows
us how at one point Edward Teller who
went on to invent the hydrogen bomb had
worries that the nuclear weapon may
start a great enough chain reaction that
it would heat up the hydrogen in the
atmosphere causing it to fuse together
and become a giant fusion bomb after
some initial calculations however almost
every scientist involved in the project
dismissed the concern but it wasn't
Albert Einstein who Oppenheimer visited
to confirm this instead Oppenheimer
consulted Arthur Compton who confirmed
there was a near zero possibility of
such a catastrophe happening